good news Amazon Prime subscribers
September 2019 brings plenty of westerns
the to Mad Max films gateways to the
stars
presidents fighting terrorists in the
sky kaijus and arnold schwarzenegger
breaking faces on mars he is the best of
what's ahead the edgy action drama
series a family man stars a renowned
Indian actor Manoj Bajpayee as an
undercover operative who works for a
government intelligence agency trying to
take down terrorist groups from the
inside the family man looks not only at
the danger he faces working for the
government but how he balances that work
with his demanding family life in August
2019 India West reported the family man
was the first Indian television series
to be showcased by Los Angeles
Television Critics Association the first
season is ten episodes long and
distracted by a dynamic duo known as
Rush and DK they've made a name for
themselves in Bollywood directing quirky
sleepers like the 2011 crime drama Shawn
the city and the 2013 zombie comedy go
ago a gun Amazon Prime doesn't have a
firm release date for the series
premiere but we know it will be
available in September starring Rosa
Salazar of elites at battle angel Fame
and Bob Odenkirk of better call Saul
Amazon Prime's undone is a unique
animated series about a woman whose
sense of reality serve as a seismic
shift after a car crash
Salazar Salma wakes in a hospital bed to
find her dead father Jacob played by
Odenkirk waiting for her as the series
unfolds
Alma's father reveals she's experiencing
time in a new nonlinear way and he
teaches her to use it so she can solve
the mystery of who killed him in the
hopes you can eventually go back in time
to prevent us murder and Dunn will be
ready to blow your mind Friday September
13th and now for a look at some of the
best movies coming to prom in September
starting with the best action flicks on
offer most of the television series
added to Amazon Prime streaming service
in September will be original content
like undone and the family man with the
notable exception of American Horror
Story apocalypse the eighth season of
the popular FX horror anthology series
apocalypse begins worth it true to its
name and nuclear apocalypse the series
stars are left in a decimated well they
have to learn to survive see how or if
they learn to cope on September 24th
September on Amazon Prime features car
chases at the end of the world Gunsmoke
epic duels and an American president
beating up Gary Oldman on a plane all of
the best action films are added to
on the same day Monday September 30th at
the end of July George Miller revealed
there are multiple sequels of 2015's Mad
Max fury road in development but if
you're more of a fan of the original
film starring Mel Gibson as a
post-apocalyptic tough guy Amazon Prime
as 1981's Mad Max - the road warrior and
1985's Mad Max Beyond Thunderdome - ass
library if you like your future action
flicks of at least a little less
apocalypse Arnold Schwarzenegger gets
his butt Samar's and 1990s trippy action
classic Total Recall effeminate me who
the hell Emma meanwhile Kurt Russell and
James Spader star in the film has
spawned a whole host of television
spin-offs 1994 stargates on the same day
Harrison Ford stars as President James
Marshall who's kidnapped by the vengeful
Gary Oldman in 1997's Air Force One and
John Travolta and Nicolas Cage assume
each other's identities in the John Woo
classic face-off even though Halloween
won't be for another month
Amazon Prime isn't wasting any time in
going for the screams September 30th
will see a long list of horror and
thriller flicks added to Prime streaming
library if you enjoy your chills with a
dash of science fiction
there's 1997's event horizon starring
Laurence Fishburne and Sam Neill
in early August we learned Death Note
actor Adam Wingard was tapped to direct
an upcoming TV series based on the film
so here's your chance to check out the
source material for more earthbound
terrors there's 2008 Cloverfield
following a group of friends trying to
survive a giant monster attack in New
York City if you're more interested in
thrillers rooted in the real world
there's 2002 s insomnia directed by
Christopher Nolan insomnia tells a story
of a sleep-deprived detective played by
Al Pacino who accidentally shoots and
kills his own partner while pursuing
suspected killer Walter Finch played by
Robin Williams primes library will also
include a number of excellent
psychological thrillers at the end of
September
including 1999's of talented mr. Ripley
starring Matt Damon and Quinn F Paltrow
and 2003 s Gothica starring Halle Berry
and a future Iron Man Robert Downey jr.
suggest that we simply increase
medication until they'd start to make
sense until I can get myself a new
doctor for more dramatic fare Amazon
Prime September 30th offerings bring war
thunder ghosts and grits Ethan and Joel
Cohen's excellent 2010 remake of 1969
classic true greats will be available
for streaming starring Jeff Bridges as a
drunken commotion Rooster Cogburn and
Hailee Steinfeld as a young Mattie Ross
for an epic much closer chronologically
to our own time
there's Oliver Stone's Vietnam War saga
platoon starring Charlie Sheen and an
incredible ensemble cast including
Willem Dafoe if you're excited about the
upcoming sequel no one was expecting
TopGun maverick you might be able to
satisfy your cravings a bit with the
1990 sports action drama Days of Thunder
starring Tom Cruise a stock car racer
Cole trickle and Nicole Kidman as
trickles neurosurgeon love interest
Claire if you want something without so
much car racing or war there's two
thousand and ones black comedy-drama
ghosts world starring Thora Birch Steve
Buscemi
and future Avengers Scarlett Johansson
you just hit every single guy in the
face the earth that's not true I just
hate all these extroverted pseudo
bohemian loser you guys up for some
reggae tonight there isn't a lot of
comedy on the whate Amazon Prime in
September but what is coming is
interesting and it all drops on
September 30th try maybe one of the few
places you'll be able to see 1994
trading mom starring [ __ ] Spacek of
Keri Fame and Anna Chlumsky of my girl
and vibe trading mom is about a trio of
siblings who cast a spell on their
nagging mother to make her disappear for
a comedy fantasy us a bit more recent
there's 2008 s ghost town starring
Mickey Gervase in his first leading film
role as a dentist you can see and
communicate with ghosts check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos but your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
you
[Music]